قالت الاداره الاداره العسكريه في
نيبروبيتروفيس ان سته اشخاص قتلوا واصيب
25 في قصف روسي استهدف احد المباني في
مدينه كريفيري جنوب شرق اوكرانيا واضافت
الاداره العسكريه ان سبعه اشخاص لا يزالون
عالقين تحت الانقاض وان الجهود مستمره
لانقاذهم وقد وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
القصف بالارهابي محملا روسيا المسؤوليه عن
كل صاروخ اطلقته وتزمن الهجوم مع اعلان
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه اسقاط عشره
صواريخ مجنحه استهدفت مدنا اوكرانيه عده
الليله الماضيه
معنا من كييف مراسل الجزيره عدنان بوريني
عدنان اذا تطورات عده في اخرها هذا القصف
على منطقه كريفيري ضعنا في اخر المستجدات
بهذا الخصوص
الدفاع انها صواريخ كروز بلغت مبنى سكنيا
او اصابه مبلغ مبنى سكنيه من خمس طبقات ما
ادى الى مقتل سته اشخاص وجرح نحو 25 شخصا
حتى الان عمليات الانقاذ ومحاوله اسعاف
الجرحى مستمره بشكل اساسي السلطات
الاوكرانيه تصف هذا الهجوم بالارهابي وهو
كان منصه لحديث مدير مكتب الرئاسه اندريه
بان المزيد من بطاريات باتريوت توفير
طائرات اف 16 المزيد من الدفاعات من الغرب
ومن الناتو هي الضمان الامنيه الوحيده
وهذا هذا الحديث جاء ليرماك في تعقيب على
هجوم على ايه حال نحن ما زلنا بترقب
النتائج هذا الهجوم حتى اللحظه بالعموم لا
يمكن عزل هذه الهجمات عن ما يحدث في عموم
الاراضي الاوكرانيه نتحدث عن تصعيد في
الجبهه الشرقيه بشكل اساسي والجبهه الجنوب
الشرقيه نتحدث عن ما يوصف هنا منطقه
عمليات خرتيستا ومنطقه عمليات تفاريا
بالامس تحدثت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
عن انه تقدما كبيرا حققه الجيش الاوكراني
هناك نتحدث عن نحو سته فاصله خمسه سته
كيلو مترات ونصف تقريبا وهو ما مجموعه 90
كيلومتر مربع تم الحديث عن استعاده
السيطره على سبع بلدات حتى الان في تلك
الجبهه يتم الحديث عن تقدم في
جبهه بخموت من جهه الاجنحه هذه هذا التقدم
وان يصفه الرئيس الاوكراني بالصعب في ظل
بعد اتصاله بقاده العمليات هناك لكنه قال
انه تقدم مهم للجيش الاوكراني وبالتالي
يمكن فهم هذه الهجمات الصاروخيه على انها
جزء من المشهد عموما شكرا لك عدنان بوريني
مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من كييف